[Music]
foreign
to you watching the Press preview of
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive to us tonight in the next
half hour we're going to see what's
making the headlines with the political
editor at HuffPost UK Kevin Schofield
and the economics editor at The
Spectator Kate Andrews both of you
welcome to the program thank you very
much for being with us this Sunday
evening first so let's have a look at
what's on some of those front pages for
tomorrow's reading starting with the
Metro it leads on the three britons who
are missing after a boat caught fire
during a red sea diving trip it's the
arrest of Nicholas surgeon on the front
of the express it reports that the
former first Minister has insisted that
she is innocent of any wrongdoing same
story dominating the front page of the
sun tomorrow which says Miss sturgeon
was questioned by police for seven hours
now the guardian tomorrow says there is
growing frustration amongst conservative
MPS over the behavior of Boris Johnson
and his allies onto the mail
claiming that the labor leader is in the
pocket of roadblocking Eco protesters
and the star reports on a new theory
that the body of Henry the first may be
buried beneath reading prisons car park
have to read a bit more about that in
just a few minutes time a reminder for
you that by scanning the QR code that
you see on screen right now during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch with us and of course we're joined
tonight as I just said by the political
editor at the HuffPost UK Kevin
Schofield and the economics editor at
The Spectator Kate Andrews let's go and
chat to them both now as I say welcome
again thank you for staying up I'm sure
way past your bedtime on a Sunday night
to be with us we are very grateful
um let's start with the express front
page going large as you can imagine on
we as what we learned today the the
arrest of Nicholas sturgeon and being
questioned under caution of course she's
been released without charge and she has
vehemently uh expressed her innocence
um let's start with the UK what do you
make of the story
it's an utterly remarkable story as you
say Nicholas surgeon has been released
without charge but it is it is really
quite something that the former first
Minister was arrested and multiple
papers are reporting that she was
questioned for seven hours the police
have said that she is a suspect in
operation branch form again to repeat
release without charge but they are
looking into the financial
irregularities around the smp's finances
Operation Branch firm goes back years
now
um as they have been looking into what
is estimated to be about 600 000 pounds
that is alleged to have been spent
potentially on campaign Finance as Oppo
instead of a second referendum and as
you say nickel surgeon has released a
statement and the statement is quite
interesting because not only does she
insist in her words Beyond doubt that
she is innocent of any wrongdoing she
also reminds people that she has
entitled that she's entitled to that
presumption of innocence she says
innocence is not just a presumation that
I am entitled to by law law and you know
this is a story now that is going to
probably go on for quite more time
um we are looking at the prospects of a
general election next year this is
obviously very bad news for the SMP it's
also possible that we may not have
answers by the time a general election
comes around and we're in really tricky
territory now where there's all only so
much that we're going to be able to say
uh in this matter but um you know very
very difficult day for the s p uh whomza
Yusuf has been desperate to separate his
party from the scandal going around uh
the finances but when you have the
former first Minister arrested and
question for Seven Answers it's near
impossible to separate Nicholas Thurston
from a party that frankly she was very
very successful
um when when she was there put aside the
policies of the SNP and the impact of
those she's thought to be one of the
most successful politicians in recent
decades in the UK so you know it's just
remarkable very fast story actually from
Nicholas urchin given the fact that she
only resigned a few months ago and we're
here now yeah and in this place a few
hours a huge amount of reaction as well
to digest I mean Kevin let's bring you
in now your political editor so this is
a story I'm sure you've been covering
closely all day I mean what do you make
of it and also the political
ramifications that potentially are
apparent now
yeah I mean it came as a real surprise
obviously if you remember
um Nicholas's husband and Peter model
who had been the smp's chief executive
at the time of his arrest is no longer
he was arrested a couple of months ago
that was followed quite soon after by
the S P's Treasurer now former Treasurer
and Colin bite
um so in a sense it was inevitable
um we were expecting Nicholas doesn't to
be arrested at some point however
um it happened on a Sunday in itself was
quite unusual and just the the simple
fact of Nicholas doesn't being arrested
is inevitably going to be a huge story
now the political implications are
potentially huge
um obviously as Kate says we have to be
a little bit careful what we see about
the investigation itself but it's um
undeniable that it's bad publicity for
the SNP and the last thing really that
Hamza Yusuf who's trying to strike out
on his own set of fresh course for the
SNP after a lengthy period in which
nickel studs and before her Alex salmond
led the party for the best part of 20
years really and these types of
headlines just bring the whole story
back into the Forefront of the minds of
photos in Scotland now what's
interesting is that support for
Independence hasn't really been affected
by all the SNP scandals it's still up
around the high 40s 50 something like
that but support for the SNP has dipped
although they are still the most popular
party in Scotland and as Kate says with
the general election coming up next year
and you know they've really got to try
and get some more
um clear blue water between themselves
and the labor party I also got a lot of
seats potentially at risk in that in
that general election and now we're
going to talk about Sir Nicholas surgeon
a lot more in our 11 o'clock hour here
on Sky News so let's just park that here
now to have a look at some more papers
while we can as well sorry typing time
onto the front page of the guardian and
we thought that politics was busy north
of the Border it hasn't stopped in
Westminster either I have to say and and
the uh Guardian tomorrow choosing I mean
they have three stories on their front
page including Nicholas surgeon's arrest
but they what they choose to go large on
is that the line that senior Tories are
telling Johnson to shut up and go away
apparently Sydney conserves as I told
Boris Johnson his allies to shut up and
go away as the Privileges committee
prepares to sign off on what's expected
to be a damning report into his conduct
and this story just keeps rumbling on
doesn't it Kate what's what's your angle
on it
if you're a News Junkie it's been a big
weekend for you because before we had
the arrest of Nicholas sturgeon we had
the resignation of Boris Johnson which
has come after he was given the heads up
that the Privileges committee uh was
likely to rule against him
um they are meeting at 11 A.M tomorrow
to finalize their conclusion looking
into their year-long inquiry on
partygate whether or not the Prime
Minister misled Parliament and they are
likely to speed up the publication of
that report now that Boris Johnson has
indeed resigned because he's resigned
there's some things we're not going to
get we're not going to get potential
recall we're not going to get Boris
Johnson in a by-election but there is
some debate now about whether or not he
could see the past that would usually be
permitted to him to access Parliament
taken away that's something that
ultimately would fall to the common
speaker to decide that there's pressure
on Tori MPS to basically come out and
have their say and this quote on the
front page of the Guardian is from Tim
Lawton who was a minister under David
Cameron and apparently he said shut up
and go away to Boris Johnson of course
we know that there are a lot of
loyalists to Boris Johnson who were
talking about giving up their own seats
and protest or where the Tory party they
feel has put Boris Johnson they put more
weight on the current prime minister
rather than the former prime minister's
actions during covid yet another
reminder that it's not just the SMP
that's at war with itself it's also the
Tory party uh and as you say a story
that is very likely to continue on I
think Boris Johnson would have been
leading every paper and all the
headlines for the rest of the week if it
hadn't been for Nicholas surgeons indeed
just briefly Kevin will he will he shut
up and go away what do you think
uh I think there's very little chance of
that
um I think now that he's now outside the
tent and he will continue huddling rocks
at Richardson for as long as he possibly
can he still blames Richardson largely
for bringing him down uh and there's no
free of any restrictions of being
conservative MP you can see what it
likes and he can do what you like so um
that's a pretty good position for Boris
Johnson to be in very uncomfortable for
Richard sunick a bit like Hamza Yusuf
you know who doesn't want the snp's wars
to be on in the headlines again the last
thing Richard wants is Boris Johnson and
partygate to be all over the paper ring
because that just reminds voters of why
they were so angry
um with Boris Johnson before he
um resigned as prime minister so you're
not a great set of um headlines for
Rishi sunak either and it'll be
fascinating to see how many more and
conservative MPS break ranks and and
decide to keep this story bubbling over
the next few days indeed and of course
we're talking about two big political
heavyweights aren't we Nicholas sturgeon
and Boris Johnson just a space one
weekend you guys have been very busy
haven't you um let's have a look at the
front page the day email before we move
to a quick break another big political
story
um regarding swella bravaman the Home
Secretary she's writing actually in in
the daily mail tomorrow saying that
she's blasting sakir starmer as being in
the pocket of the Eco mob as his party
tries to crack down on or block a
Crackdown on disruptive protests Kevin
I'm going to start with you first on
this one what do you make of it
well yeah I mean you can always rely on
on the mail to to try and um give the
conservatives a positive headline for
it's all negative pretty much everywhere
else and yes chosen to write an article
in uh the daily mail tomorrow and it was
quite interesting it's obviously a a
tactic um that can serve us are Keen to
use on labor at the moment is to try and
Link labor with just stop oil and the
disruption that their protest cause for
ordinary voters in the Public's mind
um obviously there are donations from
just up of the events have gone to the
labor party now labor have said that uh
that there's not in any way by influence
or um dictate labor policy is the
conservatives want to convince voters
that that is not the case now at laborer
and Kirsten Was preparing to make a big
um speech on energy uh the week after
next so um all eyes will be on that and
I'm sure the conservatives will be all
over to try and establish us to see some
link between just stop oil and deliver
is wanting to establish that link and
really hammer it home in the voters mind
there's not much evidence looking at the
polls that that is cutting through just
yet but you know who knows it might be
something that voters might want to
think about okay okay generally let's
bring you in what do you make of this
so-called attack line then from the Home
Secretary will it work
well it's not necessarily helpful to the
labor party that it was revealed that
one of the big backers of just stop oil
also gave over a million pounds to the
labor party uh so you know there there
are connections there in which I think
the Home Secretary can dry draw even if
it's a very thin line between the labor
party and perhaps some sympathy within
the labor party to the radical protest
of just stop oil but that's very
different than tying it directly to
kyostama and I think that's probably
where the struggle is going to be
um and you know to totally separate
labor and Tory on Law and Order these
days is becoming more and more difficult
just as it is on the economy just as it
is on a range of issues but this is
clearly an area where the Home Secretary
still thinks she can draw a distinction
and she's highlighting how much time
these protests have taken out from
police officers she estimates that it's
taken up over 12 000 police officer
shifts to deal with them when they could
be tackling far more serious crimes so
clearly an area where the Tories still
think that they can have a bit of sway
but tying it directly to the opposition
leader is going to be a little more
difficult at a cost of 14 million pounds
last year she says okay Kate for now
thank you very much Kevin thanks to you
too plenty more from both of our guests
in just a few minutes time indeed more
stories from tomorrow's front pages
including this story that's on the front
page of the Guardian the headline ofsted
overhaul fails to change schools grading
we're reading that and getting some
expert views for you and just a few
minutes time do stay with us
[Music]
thank you
hello there welcome back you're watching
the Press preview with me tonight as the
political editor at the HuffPost UK
Kevin Schofield we're also joined by the
economics editor at The Spectator Kate
Andrews welcome to you both thanks very
much for being on board and we're going
to go straight back to the guardian the
front page of that another story that
they are highlighting here is ofsted
overhaul fails to change School gradings
changes by offset they say to the way it
inspects schools have been criticized as
being nowhere near enough to reduce high
levels of stress involved after which
were blamed for the recent death of a
popular head teacher um Kate let's let's
go to you for this one what is your
reading of this story about Richard
Adams
so changes are being announced today in
terms of the way that these schools will
um uh be graded as uh no pun intended
um in order to ease some of that burden
that's being felt by teachers when their
schools are demoted and this follows on
from that very tragic suicide
um when a situation a teacher was very
stressed by that demotion however where
ofsted isn't budging is on these words
like inadequate they still want to be
able to put one word on a school to give
parents a very good indication of uh
exactly what kind of education their
kids are receiving
um and this is in big dispute and uh the
criticism today is that that one word is
not actually good enough to describe
what's going on in the school and
obviously these changes are being made
in a really delicate circumstance uh so
uh you know the difficulty around how
one labels so that parents know exactly
what's going on compared to the pressure
that might even be put on individual
teachers in many cases who will not be
responsible for what's happening overall
in the school is a clearly a very very
difficult one to strike Maybe is indeed
it actually features as well that story
on the front page The Daily Telegraph so
let's go to that paper now actually
looking at a different story their
coverage of the goings-on in Westminster
over the weekend taking a slightly
different angle you could say um cynic
urged to cut tax amid fears of
by-election losses Kevin what do you
make of this
yes so I mean Russia student really
doesn't have these problems to seek at
the moment I'll cut itself one Boris
Johnson
um Nadine Doris which now seems like a
lifetime ago it was only Friday
afternoon that she resigned with
immediate effect as an NP that was
obviously followed by Boris Johnson and
then Nigel Adams and other Boris Johnson
Ally he resigned on Saturday so these
three by-elections all varying degrees
of
um difficulty for the conservatives
obviously held by the Tories at the
moment labor very confident in Oxbridge
Boris Johnson's old seat the lid Dems
have got their eye on Mid bedfordshire
um which is and Nadine Doris's seat and
uh nice latency as well as in I think
labor sites there as well so really you
know these could be a very triple blow
potentially foreign
for a while now about cutting taxis we
know that a lot of conservative MPS
conservative about Adventures
particularly on the right of the party
are very keen that and Jeremy Hunt the
chancellor Cuts taxes as soon as
possible to give them any chance of
winning the next election they believe
so clearly that they're now using these
looming by-elections as further leverage
really and trying to pile pressure on
both Russia and Jeremy Hunt to start
cutting taxes because as I said we think
that that will be a vote winner which is
obviously what recession that really
really needs right now um okay let's
bring you in economics editor you're
very well placed to talk about tax cuts
I mean can they do it is it a
possibility what do you think
it's difficult right now it's certainly
a possibility and the tax burdens uh
post-war high in my opinion it's far too
high but this does come with trade-offs
and it's what nobody's wanted to talk
about for a long time now and that's the
other side of the Ledger which is
spending and kovitzova spend hundreds of
billions of more pounds
um and you know interest costs are up
borrowing costs are through the roof
just to service the debt to service
money that we've already spent we are
paying your record levels to do so at
the moment so if you want to cut tax I
think as Liz truss taunt the labor party
and the conservative party last Autumn
you have to make some trade-offs the tax
cuts aren't fundamentally the problem
it's promising deficit Finance tax cuts
when you're also spending you know tens
of billions and more pounds and this
Tory government under British sunak and
Jeremy Hunt has opted to spend more
money on things like their new child
care policy so and make more money for
the Kate jump in there because we are
running out of time but you'll be able
to finish your points in the 11 o'clock
hour I promise you Kate and Andrew thank
you Kate and Kevin thank you so much for
that